plusieurs années j'aime bien louer des
maisons d'été et invité les alliés et il
ya quelques années de ça c'était
maintenant c'est en italie plus tôt mais
quelques années ça c'était sur la côte
ce qu'on appelle super cannes faisait
toujours rire super cannes est bien
parti cette can je suis super kf je suis
super canon c'était il ya longtemps
thierry tu rigoles merci j'ai jamais
fumé jeu que j'ai fumé à l'âge de 38 ans
des cigarettes et je ne suis pas fumeur
de pétard quoi que ce soit et tout ça
pour brest mais sauf que après tout cas
pas sauf que cette année là cette année
la région raconte tant pis cette année
là on se retrouve à un dîner où
quelqu'un je dirai pas qui mais à
quelqu'un de notre entourage jeudi à
mais tu prends un petit pétard sur
grosso
on se sait pas c est bruno masure dia
non moi je ne fume pas bon et cette
personne que vous reconnaîtrez avec
l'accent du fait non c'est pas grave si
tu fumes pas en a certes des gâteaux je
n'ai pas situation novascience un petit
musée qui l'a pas dit à tout le monde
non et on s'est dit on va faire des
gâteaux ma pierre va remettre ça dans et
moi j'étais en cuisine les hommes et aux
artistes le soir et aux moins jeunes à
jamais de ma vie moi je suis innocent je
j'avais goûté ça et on se retrouve tous
à bouffer ça sauf diane qui pourtant
faut dire d'abord il est tombé dans la
marmite quand elle était petite
qui donc dit moi je n'en prends pas mais
je connais dans un état tous et masure
effectivement donné s'est retrouvé au
bord d'une piscine de la piscine avec
une couverture donné ça et il scotche et
parce qu'ils n'avaient jamais fumé même
sourire et leila n'y croyait mourir et
c'est diane qui l'a réconfortée
effectivement vous en donnez moi je
viens le voir je lui dis ça va parce que
je soigne et je les maintiens bien sûr
déboulant sur benjamin bratt ou le rôle
judith t'inquiète pas ça va passer c'est
que c'est que de l' angoisse tout ça et
il avait la couverture et ce jour je
croyais moi je crois que tout le monde
allait mourir
je savais que personnel mouret mais tout
le monde avait une angoisse que le
mauvais trip hop trip
il accueillera bien il est en train de
mourir il me dit tu veux que je te
montre ma vie et j'ai dit non ça va j'ai
autre chose à faire et il l'a envoyé de
rapport mais en foot année voilà la
première fois que j'ai pu mais vrai le
2-2 un truc là c'était chez barclay j'y
vais assez mal avec jacques martin et
beaucoup de gens fumaient dont un
chanteur dont j'ai oublié le nom faille
avec qui je veux non à noter les vivants
et les morts et surtout besoin jackson
oui je suis sûr j'aime les manches et
j'ai vu là-bas aussi
surtout lorsqu il ne faut pas donc il ya
besoin et on me dit de fumée ar je fus
et le problème c'est que je n'arrivais
pas à avaler
le jeune fils de souvent comme utiliser
d'imagés ou loisirs dont alors aucun cas
me busch néant gauche rate habilités à
se marier que certaines femmes
je parle de barclay et enfin j'avale
jamal et jacques martin le père de six
enfants étaient partis dans le salon un
but loin et moi enfin comme j'avale
j'avais ont même fermé les oreilles le
nez va ça commence à faire des voeux et
là je me suis rendu compte que je veux
que je pensais qu'au cul
gp dont il avait entendu parler de cul
pied et salon à côté j'ai vu ça j'ai
entendu des gens leur entraîneur veut
rentrer thierry digne un truc c'est sûr
qu'il y avait rien dans les coquillages
et donc dans la salle aux côtés des ac
et là j'étais dans un état mais dans un
étal
j'avais les deux comme on dit des tasses
et là je me suis rendu compte que je dis
ah tu as peur quand je suis ridicule
pour très longtemps encore il faudra
bien que tu manques hulot plutôt bon
dieu 1 jacques martin il se trouve que
après cette soirée mêlant apprirent ont
finalement on avait tous eu un mauvais
trip parce que vraiment on n'était pas
habitué à ça il était prévu que le
dernier soir le soir on doit rendre la
maison on recommence et voilà et c'est
parti et on fait et on fout et on fout
ça normalement dans des brioches en fait
est là ce jour là un attaché de presse
qui se trouvent dans ma maison dit est
ce que ça te gêne que x je peux pas lire
son nom mais vous allez comprendre tu
devais le dire quand même tout à l'heure
que onac madame 1 vient il va faire
l'olympia bientôt elle vient avec nous
dîner ce soir est ce que ça t'embête
sinon c'est enfin non ça m'embête pas il
devait venir déjeuner à la peine au
dernier moment elle dit non je peux pas
venir déjeuner je vais venir dîner elle
arrive
il s'était déjà préparé tu vois tout ça
et elle s'installe tu peux dire qu'il
sait cette note nick hornby
c'est terrible c'est pire que tout on
est 6 7 et annie sachetat la table et on
rigole et on s'amuse et arrive alors il
faut que je dise qui en avait dans des
brioches et que pendant que les autres
étaient partis à intermarché avec
d'autres potes on se dit oh non mais
très bien aussi dans le taboulé faut
jamais faire ça dans votre édition donc
temps pour moi j'arrive ne lui faut
jamais faire ça parce que c'est vraiment
dangereux quoi surtout avec une dame
d'un certain âge comme comme comme cette
table et a n'a rien à ce moment je tape
voulait à la fin du tabou et c'est parti
photo audio et jetable et on en était
mais malade parce que vous n'avez pas
ces extraits savait vraiment l'effet à
jonathan vous dire que vous dit quelque
chose
rires je n'ai aucune expérience aucune
expertise comme on dit maintenant d'une
il avait une grande expertise aucune
expertise sur tarn à albi par d'or sur
c'est sur ces choses de de paradis
artificiels mais je sais parle pas récit
et aussi pour en avoir un peu tâté de
ces trucs là quand on fume du h on peut
doser
on peut savoir à chaque bouffée où on en
est non non mais dans un gâteau
moi j'ai un souvenir d'un gâteau au
chocolat où on avait mis en au maroc
il a émis de haschich qu'ils avaient
achetés qui étaient 48 fois plus fort
que la chaîne qu elle soit à paris dans
le gâteau à qui j'ai vu des femmes se
déboîte rails et devant leurs maris
banquiers on dira et comme ça
et les récuser pupuke drôlement fou
alors allons donc ça peut rendre fou les
gens c'est canon dans cette fête jamais
au manger très dangereux jamais faire du
faux non plus pas en fumée
et alors faut quand même que je raconte
la suite le dans la nuit on était tous
persuadés qu'elle allait mourir
non non pas non parce que moi qui chante
et tata yoyo et et vous y avez
frédérique lebon à l'imitateur qui
reprennent et les nations et les
corniches hanté par dalida a chanté par
marie chanté par toutes les voies y
avait aussi et c'était parti puisse
aller plus on sentait mal est
particulièrement elle et elle dit je
sais que c'est pour surprise surprise
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu